petit matin à 7h de longues files
d'attentes se sont formées dans le calme
près des centres d'enregistrement des
migrants ça devient folie nous avons 10
millions de pauvres 6 millions de
chômeurs dans notre pays et ont déjà des
ghettos communautaires des ghettos de
zones de non droit et on nous demande
d'ajouter encore d'immigration fatous à
sanaa ça n'a aucun sens et par beaucoup
de ces migrants des soudanais
principalement ont en réalité très peu
d'informations ils n'ont que quelques
secondes pour décider de l'avenir que
nous souhaitons mettre à l'abri
l'ensemble des personnes qui se
trouvaient encore aujourd'hui sur le
campement et dont la grande majorité a
fui les guerres les persécutions le cac
repart lentement il sera géo localiser
en permanence par cette petite boîte
placée à côté du chauffeur des bâches en
plastique autour des sièges revoyez les
images j'ai 100 n'ose même pas imaginer
la raison pourquoi cette entreprise de
bus a pris la décision de vaches et les
sièges de ces bustes et ans attend aussi
bien entendu à une chasse à l'homme on
sait qu'il ya au moins 1000 places qui
ont été libérés dans des centres de
rétention des prisons quelque part ou
luz on va les arts et la police va les
arrêter au nahd dans notre monde des
bombes de menaces de déplacements de
populations qui sont immenses
revoyez les déplacements de population
dans le monde sont sans précédent et
actuellement 50 millions de personnes 50
millions qui ont dû s'enfuir de chez
elle
combien coûte un pain au chocolat jean
françois copé et ça dépend détails je
pense que ça doit être aux alentours de
2 10 ou 15 centimes d'euros par litre de
lait combien ça coûte
ça dépend on voulait acheter voilà entre
0,60 centimes d'euro et un gros 50 sur
les ponts
c'est juste 100 g de chouquettes je
l'aimais off aller je les mettrais au
delà de 1 1 euro en dessous de 2 et au
delà d'eux en dessous de 2 c difficile à
trouver
vous l'avez fait perdre l'élection de
2012 françois d'ailleurs je suis un
citoyen j'ai le droit de voter pour qui
je veux corinne rire ou que je connais
bien ils étaient quatre fois candidat à
la présidentielle le prix je me fais des
choses je dirigeais l'udf non ça on peut
pas dire qu'on ait fait des choses
ensemble il a été ministre est question
nationale rien touché en 5 ans répartis
les pattes on doit les avoir autour de
80 entre 90 centimes et un euro il pas
quelques liquides je vais souvent
dimanche matin dans la boulangerie de
chez moi j'achète un croissant un pain
au chocolat part dans une forêt native
et une ficelle
j'en ai pour 3 euros marc c'est là qu'on
voit qu'il est urbain ce citadin parce
que chez moi dans la sarthe on parle pas
de ficelle on dit pas ça qui me plaisait
quand j'ai acheté des chouquettes chemin
de l'école c'était la boulangère d'un
chocolat 1 euros 30
merci monsieur debré je crains d'avoir
été un peu mou de la boulangère qui
était ainsi corpulente j'avais à
l'époque à l'école primaire
cette histoire de pains au chocolat ça
lui colle comme un sparadrap je pense